Warhammer 40k Inquisitor Mota is an
action RPG which faithfully evokes the
atmosphere of the grim 41st millennium
it's an intense experience focusing on a
gameplay with a spectacular display of
destruction recalls the sense of
constant warfare take a look at your
surroundings let the glorious carnage
commence in the name of the Emperor and
know that nothing can survive the
devastation you are going to unleash the
new in-house developed cool tech engine
combines with updated physics grants of
welcome diversity in how different types
of attacks affect the environment the
environment also has a significant role
in the gameplay Inquisitor Mata is an
action RPG with some fundamental
improvements and one of these new
additions is the cover system which
grants a tactical layer to the game
covers are fixed obstacles to provide a
more realistic approach to the
firefights the first rule of the cover
system is that both inquisitors and
their enemies can use certain objects to
shield themselves from hostile attacks
rule number two since the cover is also
cost the environment it can be destroyed
depending on their size creatures can
use obstacles to mitigate incoming
damage the type and the material will
determine how much damage a cover can
absorb most of the obstacles can be
destroyed over time but it also depends
on the weapon of choice bolt ammunition
will break down the barriers gradually
chipping away the defenses on the other
hand class guns disintegrate most covers
with a couple of large glass
under relentless fire even massive
columns can collapse burying Friend or
Foe under the rubble destructible
environment can be either a benefit or
hazard dangerous objects like
pressurized containers can explode upon
impact which in turn will create a
physical blowback effect it is an
effective way to [ __ ] all of the
creatures caught in the blast all-in-all
destructible environment is one of the
key elements in Inquisitor Marta
there'll be some more to follow stay
tuned for more videos and welcome to the
grim world of Warhammer 40k